c'est maître gims et vianney qui sont
accusés de plagiat leur sang sont là
même qui figure sur l'album bien sûr
ceinture noire de maître gims ressemble
à un clip un clip qui est sorti un mois
plus tôt ce clip en question c'est les
passantes de georges brassens et sa
réalisatrice crie au plagiat
regardez on a une comparaison entre les
deux pays vous allez me dire ce que vous
en pensez là sur le clip de la chanson
le clip sexy lucky luke garder
[Musique]
j'aimais et maître gims qui chantent la
même c'est déjà 30 millions d' écoute en
ligne et ce clip sorti le 20 avril
sauf que cette chanson porte peut-être
trop bien son nom hélas ces images de la
même c'est comme si on les avait déjà
vus quelque part pour la journée de la
femme une certaine charlotte abramoff
avait réalisé un clip sur la chanson les
passantes et quand on voit ces portraits
en plan américain sur fond pastel d'or
bah c'est vrai que c'est un peu la même
dans les deux un système de cube
lumineux et défont jaune rose vert
copier-coller presque à la nuance près
les internet ont été alertés par la
fameuse charlotte ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les deux chanteurs sont
accusés de plagiat comme le dit si bien
m gibbs mais plagiant ou aspirations de
maître gims est via les dons privés
faudrait toujours mais oui c'est
absolument pas un plagiat
l'art n'est que répétition à ce moment
là on recopie tous léonard de vinci à
l'origine donc je trouve que je trouve
que l'accusation franchement est
dégueulasse ce sont deux artistes à part
entière
ce n'est pas une copie mais je vois la
comparaison il leur pastel parviennent
équipe on est bien utilisé les mêmes
couach est elle la même manière et la
même esthétique au niveau des cadres
dont le montage de cette artiste qui est
une artiste d'ailleurs bruxelloise très
engagé féministes qui a beaucoup
d'allant
c'est dommage elle fait un mauvais buzz
sur elle alors qu'anne est très très
talentueuse et n'a aucunement un plagiat
c'est complètement stupide
oui marques sont tous trompés sur
l'académie des neuf ans patrick jarry
venir sur ma part l'assemblée
moi ça me fait penser tout de suite
attaqué sur lindsey van est très
sincèrement il râle pas besoin d'aller
s'inspirer droits de tous ces
magnifiques au travail qu'il a fait aux
siens l'artiste